[Music]
well these two appear to be the picture
of a friendly exes Ben Stiller and his
estranged wife Christine Taylor were all
smiles while out and about in NYC on
Monday this was the first time the two
have been spotted together publicly
since announcing their separation in May
2017
what's your secret what's your soup
what's the secret you think to a
successful marriage in Hollywood it's
not easy sense of humor I have to say
sense of humor is the greatest thing
right huit laugh yes we have to make
make everybody laugh makes everybody
happy according to an eyewitness the
exes enjoyed a two-hour lunch together
before they were snapped by fotox at the
time of their split the couple released
this joint statement to et with
tremendous love and respect for each
other and the 18 years we have spent
together as a couple we have made the
decision to separate adding quote our
priority will continue to be raising our
children as devoted parents and the
closest of friends life is life right we
all have to deal with the things life
throws at us so you got to have a sense
of humor about it and if you can share
that I think that is a huge thing the
pair share two kids and have seemingly
yet to finalize a divorce
[Music]
[Applause]